bio tout le monde s'est excusé
aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur
inscriptions hudgens terrebonne donc
inscrite sur un mode du jeu donc ce
terme une extension gratuite 1 donc à
contenu additionnel gratuit 1 donc je
suis super le oui allez c'est parti au
commence tout de suite c'est en anglais
malheureusement c'est pas que j'ai
craqué le jeu je les achetais 7 euros
sur steam
c'est juste que il ya il est pas
disponible en français c'est que en
anglais voilà puis les criques janvier
1986 ça ça remonte à l'époque où ma mère
écoutait ok faut se calmer à annaba
l'air écouter des chansons d'un petit
peu un petit peu hippie ou ça casse
parmi elles deux parties alors lunch
bague find flash lite faut que je trouve
une une lampe torche alors je peux pas
attendre ici et les mots je veux pas
attendre ici encore plus longtemps
je vais essayer d'appeler les coop terre
j'ai laissé ma lampe torche pour toi on
se voit bientôt sarah hockey notre
formule une sur neuf au keynote
supposerait qu'il faut trouver toutes
les notes pour gagner ce doit être une
histoire comme ça tous les coups alors
oui la fameuse lampe torche brocciu sos
la source et oui on se fait bien chez ba
très bien pas écouté je crois que j'ai
fouillé ce qu'il fallait on s'en va
alors c'est par où est ce qu'il ya un an
ça ça m'a l'air d'être un chemin très
bien allez on y va
n'empêche les graphismes de jeu sont
assez assez assez assez puissant il faut
dire ce qui est par contre notre homme
est une petite tenue de chevalier dans
le noir en règle il habillé en chevalier
genre oh oh oh je suis dans les bois
pour aller chercher ma princesse et
mcgraw jacky ça c'est fou alors signe à
cannes follow this in the wind pad je
peux à suivre ces pancartes jusqu'à un
ipad
salut salut et qu'est ce tu veux ça
travaille pas non j'ai pas envie d'avoir
une excuse kaka déjà vu quelqu'un puisse
y ont fait tache en bord de la route
comme ça doit cesser
ah bah non même pas le faut que je parle
bien j'aimerais bien voler ton sac à
merde
get that night away from mais revient là
je croyais qu'on était co peg alors le 9
janvier l'hélicoptère nous a laissés ici
cet endroit est incroyable et le guide a
l'air vraiment cool c'est vraiment
peaceful donc peas est à nowa narbonne
format bon allez y à rien à des
kilomètres
voilà ok donc ça c'était mon anglais
plutôt nul que vous avez pu le voir
alors pourquoi j'ai remarqué mme stock
en étant la langue il ya une pression
qui monte donc je pense aux mfg il ya
des salles bruit là ça ne m'inspire pas
je n'ai pas envie d'être inspiré par ça
j'aimerais bien qu'on contrôle des
stocks et qu'on gagne quand même caisse
quai des arts et blizzard les douaisiens
olala c'est quoi c'est ça le bruit trop
le chef mon dieu c'est juste un truc
genre comme si un mec oury en mode robot
naruto comme ça non on va éviter de
perdre du temps parce que ma mes jours
sont comptés que cette batterie qui
n'est pas du tout illimité
il y avait un autre chemin juste avant
j'aurais peut-être dû le prendre
finalement j'aurais peut-être pu trouver
d'accord la belle a un animal en train
de mourir peut-être à bonsoir bonsoir
bien sûr pas confiance si je suis la
bourse de sauver vos amis quand là
dessus à temps comme on nous parle
et ça va octroyer on se calme je vais
tous les deux la chaise d'accord ah bah
non je dois te faire c'est toi
m'apprennent tu sais je batte embrassés
pour que tu vives mais je n'embrasse pas
les morano un palais crâne
alors est ce qu aurait pas une petite
batterie something les médias américains
quelque chose à remercier notre camp la
dernière nuit
les choses sont devenus bizarres je n'ai
pas vu le couple brésilien depuis des
jours
il fait très froid bilé est en train
d'essayer de réparer
ouais j'ai une note super ça ça par
contre c'est cool alors ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va allumer le feu hop
là comme ça je pense que
parfait je connais tant de mal en pis et
on verra douchez à mon avis on alloue
wata foie gras ça ça ça c'est trippant
ça serait plus bas je pense que la voie
il n'y a pas d'herbe
c'est à dire qu'il ya un petit un petit
truc à faire la grève j'aimerais juste
ne pas me tromper en fait n'en fait rien
à faire rien à faire on va préférer un
[ __ ] mais c'est dingue quoi j'ai tard
la lampe et et de suite
il ya ce à quoi c'est fou c'est parce
que ces bracelets le truc qu'on a vu en
gros un qui a tué bon bah je te laisse 1
je dois vraiment trouvé ma princesse
coûte j'espère que tes vacances se sont
bien passées en tout cas abyss pas trop
de soleil untel a un petit peu laissé
chez black plutôt basse oui alors tout
droit ou à gauche
[ __ ] on n'a pas de mains pour n'a rien
alaya des affaires déjà on va prendre
tout de suite les affaires c'est
n'hésitez évidemment mais alors
qu'est-ce qu'une best donc locatif ne le
regarde pas d'accord pourquoi pas puis
les quick mapfre y est comme ça oui oui
presse tap to use the map
oh oui alors ça c'est magnifique ça
j'adore donc on voit un peu la map
oui effectivement y'a rien aux alentours
n'y a même pas un petit un petit à petit
intermarché un petit carrefour un petit
leader price pour pour acheter des
tueries
parce qu'on n'a pas d'amis mais cette
fois et voilà cette phrase était allé au
coaching bat free mining et j'ai pu que
ce sont 3 % de batterie comment vous
dire qu'actuellement je ne le vis pas
spécialement bien ce qui est plutôt
normal
par contre les troubles il ya plusieurs
chemins ça m'angoisse un peu parce que
je vais louper des notes veuillez
l'afobat on va aller à gauche avant que
la droite va aller à gauche par la ja
pas un truc là-bas très bien les jeux
d'horreur qui font travailler ton
imagination parce que tu fais caca
coyotes
voilà alors
donc la bahia le campement encore donc
là en fait en train de perdre bien de la
batterie comme il faut comme un vieux
lâche super d'accord super j'aime perdre
10% de batteries gratuitement parce que
je veux faire tous les chemins mais oui
c'est ma passion tard est je vous jure
ce bruit à écouter il super angoissant
par contre les arbres sont un petit peu
en caoutchouc c'est peut-être pour ne
pas qu'ils qui tombent face aux séismes
je ne sais pas c'est envisageable 1
alors je fais maintenant on va se
bouffer un énorme screamer d'ici peu
vous allez voir hadja katios parfait
c'est vrai pas un petit alors bill est
allé et a cherché le couple de
brésiliens et il n'est jamais revenu
j'ai très peur bruit ce qui est normal
qui n'aurait pas pas là il ya quelque
chose quelque part ici dans les bois
nous devons nous baril d'ici et je dois
trouver le guide donc le guide en fait
il a fait son mec j'ai pas jamais lavés
bonne chance à lui legrand lâche le gros
gros lâche
du coup on a trouvé notre ça c'est assez
cool à ce serait bien si on pouvait tout
les trouver alors moi je crois moi
j'aime bien les petits chemins comme ça
parce qu'ils amènent généralement faire
une note vers quelque chose qu'on n'est
pas supposé trouver
ouais donc là il ya un énorme art 2 sec
je vais faire j'espère juste que je vais
pas tomber un cours de bacri et pourquoi
cet homme de la paix nourriture ça mais
c'est vraiment super comme je fus tain
je suis très content ah pardon mais seul
arbre nokia n'est rien voilà donc ça
c'est l arnaque du siècle
actuellement je crois qu'il est clair
tous les chemins que j'ai fait la base
ce chemin là je l'ait pas fait donc on
va y aller vite fait y a rien rien du
tout on se casse oh [ __ ] le panneau et
d'ipad l'a fait peur j'ai toujours
détesté les hélicos j'ai toujours existé
1 parce que ce h peuvent eux aussi à
dire quelque chose
oui je n'ai pas d'idée on va lui même qu
en direct pour pas consommer trop de
batterie dites moi quel battre ici dans
cette boîte de chasse qui ster je veux
c'est à dire ses terres wata phoque
watts
ah ok qu'est ce que c'était que cette
créature
on aurait dit le mec d'aléas c'est dans
les trains fantômes dans les fêtes
foraines ya toujours un mec déguisé a
souvent un gorille d'ailleurs je vois
pourquoi elle qui fait peur aux gens et
voilà on aurait dit exactement ça alors
témoin ce cas ce qu'assure ce cas s'il
était fait tabou est pas j'avais alors
y'a quoi là on peut on peut passer à
droite comme ça ou alors aller à gauche
on va aller à droite la ba voila j'ai
bien fait un petit chemin cacher et à
frank esser
envoyé sur ma tête la peur pendant
quelques secondes le mec qui n'est pas
absolument pas pas serein du tout dans
cette forêt avec cet homme un petit peu
poilu qui qui ne veut pas pas vraiment
du bien également
[ __ ] mais c'est super bien fait c'est
incroyable
alors il ya quelqu'un dans cette cape
ann ont par contre il ya une baisse vers
un oui magnifique ya pas une note là
dedans just a bunch of fresh je pense
que ça veut dire être un morceau d'os ne
suivant pas jackpot batterie oui ou non
la note a pas loin de prendre au cul de
sac
l'aventuré très très périlleuse
actuellement je me fais littéralement
kaka 2 jean vidal à gauche succède
suivante on a passé haut mais que
vois-je 1 à dire dans sa teinte alors
attendez pedro mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ça a c'est un joli sac de couchage
voilà hier d'accord c'est le bas ces
deux monstres
on est à 7 sur 9 mon dieu peut-être
allons-nous gagner on a vu à quoi
ressemble le mensonge est un essai comme
ici qu il s'appelle un gros fleurs be et
le monstre est un flamby attention 3,2 à
cette blague était nous lâcher ou
commencent tous habitués du lâcher de
l'affreux journée m'a fait une chance
alors batterie manning bon là je suis
plutôt heureux 70% de batterie wahou ne
fait plus jamais ça arrête
si tu venais même si on a juste à côté
là bas ne le fais plus jamais ça enfin
juste à côté à deux kilomètres avait
fait encore actif il eu à le corton avec
moi j'ai hurlé papon sur le chihuahua au
caire
on peut aller à gauche ou à gauche là
bas mon avis un chemin secret avec un
petit comprend secret ah ça c'est pas
propre du tout d'accord
attention il va dire oh non rod fanni
pack n'est pas une note hugo jean zay
rock'n'rolla je me casse parfait
là on peut pas aller vers la bas si on
peut aller vers la bas mais un chemin
vers la barre regardez il ya un truc
vert là bas je le sais je le sens va
trouver un campement arrête arrête
j'ai pas mangé la haye laurière lydia
morte pourquoi tu me donnes moi je suis
juste un bon gros chevallier beau avec
une grosse moustache est un gros cuir
qu'il veut que j'ai trouvé sa princesse
voilà comment va aller à gauche
je pense qu'on a plus trop chaud
actuellement je sais quoi faire je me
coupais de la bûche peut-être pas bon
alors à une box à les batteries
émergence ifric annecy mais 140e
d'accord donc c'est une radio mille six
cent quarante points 4 ce sera la
fréquence d'urgence
william james bays à angers toutes les
notes aux eaux à ça quand même ça je
m'en remets pas le coup du on voit le
corps à trois kilomètres juste au moment
où ils se penchent il fait encore
code dame est ce qu'on peut dire que
on va rechercher jusqu'à l'île olala la
technique du lâche
oui alors bon moi je m'en fous on a
toutes les notes je me casse je veux
juste arrivé à aller l'eee pad
olalala nicolas lang clignote c'est à
dire qu'il est pas oui une radio live
alors radio may be a key west son mari
peut-être que je peux appeler john the
bacon wizo generator tu veux que je que
j'allume le bacon au qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce que c'est que ça landing light
y est ce qu elle même ok donc le
générateur et doit être quelque part ici
à les [ __ ] à aller où
allez allez allez du moins qu'à une
batterie de là dedans
we need for wii oh j'aime ça
j'adore alors le générateur oui oui je
pense que c'est ça un espèce de et nous
sourit gérard darel didier et contador à
damned starter ai dit ok
commandes comme aller
bien celui-là bien sûr la bad et gpa
match
mais ce n'est pas pour eux le mac do all
à la hausse génial on a eu les cinq
notes sur 9 9 9 sur 9 pardon et voilà on
a fini j'espère que cette petite vidéo
de 15 me faisant un plus pour une fois
c'est plus longue habitude je vais
essayer d'en faire développer longue
parce que vous avez aimé ça et c'est age
of à gala qui a aussi participé à ce
mode
en tout cas ça vous a plu vous invite à
jeter le jeu il est à 7 euros jusqu'à
vendredi prochain moitié prix ce qui
n'est pas rien mais on se retrouve
bientôt ans de ma vie de chat du monde
puise à bientôt et moi pour fêter ça je
vais me coller et à bon allez on en voit
là trop qui c'est que cette merde et
salut